a briga mais engraçada que vocês vão ver
na vida de vocês é dois irmãos para ver
quem é que vai usar o banheiro tu tá
entrando no banheiro Ei não não já
estava indo já não ligeirinho vou só bem
ligeirinho Não não eu já tô com a toalha
já ó Faz é tempo que eu tô com a toalha
eu já tô com a toalha O que que tem a
ver eu já estou com a toalha não pô
espera só cagar para tu tomar banho
rapaz ia tomar banho já tô com a toalha
já ligeirinho irmão eu cago eu boto
força assim meio rapidão depois vai mano
caga rápido caga ligeiro que eu vou sair
já tô atrasado não dá dois minutos que
tu começa a cagar Bora a moral dentro do
banheiro mesmo né Bora meu filho Ei Ave
Maria tá cagando é um hipopótamo né
você não tá cagando você tá